this has become a pretty hot topic the
problem with
anime original content that is because
of the promise neverland and well
it's complete deviation from the manga
only two or three episodes into the
second season
and it's bothered the majority of fans
of the series which
is completely warranted anytime a show
strays away from the source material
it's going to bother people regardless
of whether the adaptation is great or
not
and i'm not saying that all anime
original content is terrible either
but the biggest difference i feel like
is if you make one mistake
with anime original content the studio
has no one to blame but themself
and i think that is inherently the issue
at hand that creating independent
content like completely changing the
plot of the show
is like walking on a tightrope slip up
once and you have the wrath
of the anime and manga community on you
whether that's a good or bad thing
and today that's what i'm gonna try and
explain i just think that it's a really
interesting issue and that it has a
pretty long history in anime as well
so let's get into it
well before promise neverland one of the
first big shows to do this was the
original full metal alchemist adaptation
the manga wasn't finished when the anime
aired so they went
and made their own ending but something
i think is really interesting about
fullmetal alchemist anime original
ending or large part of the series
actually is that it wasn't bad
and sure manga fanatics can come at me
for saying it but after watching it i
mean
yeah brotherhood is leagues ahead of it
but it was still very enjoyable to me
which is important to mention that not
all anime original content should be
immediately taken as terrible as ruining
the series
as a pretty avid manga reader i would
never want a series to become anime
original
but to immediately assume it's bad is
really rash
but you could also argue that it's just
our due diligence
our way of respecting the work the
mangaka has put into making a series
that their fans enjoy that they're proud
of
which is also very very valid
let's move on to the promised neverland
because it's the most recent example
that really needs to be understood
now if you aren't aware if you're like
living under a rock or something
the promise neverland has officially
went to anime original
and i've only read a bit of the manga
past the anime so i don't know how
everything goes in the series
but i've read enough and done enough
research i think to understand why
people are so frustrated
one well i mean it's anime original
something that off the bat will piss
people
off and two and most importantly
it's cut out one of the best arcs and
some of the best content in the whole
series as a result
the ending of the manga didn't seem to
get a super good reception by its
fanbase again
some people enjoyed it but as a
generalization and so it seems like the
studio wanted to avoid that
and is over correcting as a result
but that ended up taking out great
material from the series which is
severely upsetting
like the ending was bad so they just
decided oh i know let's just completely
get rid of everything up until the
ending to fix that
like what and it's different from the
case with fullmetal alchemist because
the manga was even finished by that
point but with promise neverland it is
everyone knows how the series finishes
and that's a big reason why they're
upset
and to bring up what i was talking about
in the beginning of the video the
promise neverland is now at that point
where anything remotely upsetting in the
show
becomes very upsetting as a result every
step taken away from the original series
in an arc that was considered to be
really good
makes it all worse and worse which is
kind of tragic
i mean look i'm not taking the studio
aside here because they've certainly
made some pretty rash
decisions in the second season
adaptation but if you let me play the
devil's advocate for a moment
would season 2 still be bad if there
were no manga to compare it to
the problem with anime original content
is exactly that
that we can no longer judge the second
season objectively because
we're already biased already predisposed
to want it to follow the manga the
original path it was meant to take
not to say that the anime original
content is some kind of masterpiece
and that we're being stupid by comparing
it to the manga but to return to the
full monogamous case i mean the original
series has a my anime list rating of
8.16
it's pretty good it's not a 9.19 like
brotherhood but it's still
really good anime original content the
series standalone
in a vacuum is pretty damn good and we
have incredible shows like code geass
which are completely anime original so
it's not like the shows can't be trusted
in the hands of studios in the first
place
but it's thought provoking to think of
whether a show that has stopped
following the manga
is still good without having any biases
in place beforehand
i mean until brotherhood came out the
original fullmetal alchemist was pretty
widely accepted even if it wasn't an
accurate adaptation
so why have things changed or have they
even changed
is fullmetal alchemist just an anomaly
an exception to the anime original genre
are all the others bad well it's
important to note that fullmetal
alchemist came out in 2003
anime was way smaller with western
audiences at the time
i mean the only one of the shows among
my favorite anime personally that were
around by that point were legend of the
galactic heroes and one piece
so it definitely goes to show that i
think people were just glad to get
anything
at that point but all of the most
popular examples of series turning into
anime original content in anime
history that i'm aware of like soul
eater tokyo ghoul second season
are all thought of in a bad light which
certainly says something
whether it's that the series themselves
really did turn bad
or if the new content just didn't meet
the expectations of fans
and again i want to say that i'm not
coming to the defense necessarily of
making anime original content of a show
that has
proper source material to adapt from
and i think the promised neverland case
specifically is one of the worst
it's cutting out all of the content
following the first season arguably one
of the biggest shifts and changing
points in the series
to pursue a more enjoyable ending which
is ironic
because i don't think anyone will be
satisfied with the ending considering
how much has changed but
i don't know i don't really think
there's one concrete
solution to this issue if there was one
in the first place but it should
certainly be talked about
i think people are quick to crap on
anime original content without even
bothering to objectively look at the new
material itself
but you know maybe that's not a bad
thing
again maybe it's what we should do to
respect the mangaka and the work he's
put into it
which i honestly believe to be mostly
the case
but granted it is ultimately the
studio's decision they are the ones that
even let the mangaka series get animated
in the first place
it's their choice studios don't often
work closely with mangaka's on active
adaptations because
well they do what they think is best for
their organization what'll get them
money what'll make them profit
which isn't really that admirable
working with the mangaka themselves
seems like the best way but
who am i to say i'm just a small
youtuber criticizing huge companies
worth millions
i enjoyed the first season of promise
neverland but i haven't even watched
past the second episode of the second
season
because well one i'm too lazy and two
because i really haven't heard anything
good about it
so maybe i'm part of the problem the
continued stigmatization of anime
original works
or maybe i'm unknowingly doing justice
by the original creator
who knows as always this has been the
anime culture corner i hope you enjoyed
the video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses